[музика]
Щиро вітаємо Ми раді що ви дивитесь нашу
програму У фокусі Європа уявити собі
Британію без неї досі Було неможливо
після смерті королеви Єлизавети II
британці і британки тримаються разом
об'єднані у своїй скорботі за улюбленою
монархинею
всі ми завжди мали лише одну королеву і
вона була людиною якою ми захоплювались
величезна втрата
мені неймовірно сумно через те що ми її
втратили вона була чудовою представницею
нашої країни
вона була світлом для нашої країни і для
нас
під час правління королеви Єлизавети
другої змінилися аж 15 прем'єр-міністрів
королева без сумніву була винятковою
монархинею її довго життя це служіння
королівському дому
жоден глава держави жодна монархиня не
правили так довго як королева Єлизавета
II для Великої Британії Це була
константа упродовж 70 років у часи
драматичних змін завжди дисциплінована
та завжди свідома свого обов'язку
Елізабет народилася у 1926 році за 10
років на престол зійшов її батько Джордж
і Елізабет стала крон принцесою до своїх
нових обов'язків вона сталася серйозно
[музика]
я заявляю Що все своє життя коротке чи
довге я присвячу служінню вам і нашій
великій королівській родині
це Вона показала також і під час Другої
світової війни Єлизавета пройшла
військову службу як слюсар з ремонту
автомобілів відразу після війни вона
одружилася із морським офіцером Філіпом
маун беттеном а вже за рік народився
принц Чарльз перший із чотирьох дітей
у лютому 1952 року помер її батько
король Георг 6
крон принцеса стала королевою єлизаветою
II лише у 25 років
Хоча вона й не мала прямої політичної
влади але для багатьох британців була
моральним авторитетом символом
згуртованості та історії країни
королева успадкувала престолу у той час
коли Британська імперія втрачала свій
вплив колишні колонії тоді здобували
свою незалежність
критики скаржаться королева Єлизавета II
ніколи не вибачалась за несправедливість
колоніальної епохи попри численні
подорожі світу
десятиліттями Єлизавети жила тихим
подружнім життям на відміну від інших
членів королівської родини її чоловік
Філіп помер навесні 2021 року через
пандемію коронавірусу поховання
відбулось у вузькому колі Єлизавета
сумували на самоті це зворушило багатьох
запам'ятаються і сцени із її улюбленими
корги незважаючи на витримані придворні
церемонії були маленькі моменти в яких
королева дозволяла проявитися іншим
сторонам як у своєму гумору Я знаю чого
ти хочеш за станом здоров'я вона більше
не могла брати участь у деяких
урочистостях з нагоди 70-річчя
перебування на троні але Вона
продовжувала виконувати свій обов'язок
за два дні до смерті Вона зустріла нову
британську прем'єр-міністрку
[музика]
тепер навіть критики британського
королівського дому віддають шану
королеві за життя задля служіння своїй
країні
тепер королем є її старшою сина через
третій Він успадкував величезний тягар
оскільки Йому доведеться довести що
монархія у Великій Британії все ще
дійсно актуально початок його правління
припадає на непростий час адже
Великобританія перебуває у важкій
економічній кризі під час свого
проголошення Чарльз назвав саме свою
матір взірцем для виконання завдань що
чекають на нього попереду
це багато вікова церемонія і знову
повторюється уперше за 70 років
[музика]
принц Філіпа Артур Джордж є нашим єдиним
законом правителем чарльзам третім
кошеня нового монарха
цього разу фіксується сотнями камер
мобільних телефонів люди хочуть бути
присутніми на офіційному початку нової
ери щоб відчути це
у середині на задовго до цього Так звана
рада з успадкування престолу до якої
входять також провідні політики і Члени
королівської сім'ї офіційно оголосила
Чарльза королем уперше пряму трансляцію
веде телебачення
Я намагатимусь наслідувати поданий мені
надихаючи приклад
дотримуючись Конституції та прагнучи
миру
злагоди та процвітання для народу
України
королева померла після обіду в четвер у
замку балморал на шотландському нагір'ї
мирно як заявили в палаці
Коли ввечері оголосили новину приходить
скорбота офіційно і цілком особисто
країна завмирає
вона була чудовою жінкою Вона присвятила
своє життя країні ми їй дуже вдячні
А вона означала для мене та моєї сім'ї
все її почуття єдності прихильність її
служіння суспільству Невдовзі після
звістки про смерть королеву вшановує
нова прем'єр-міністр калістраз дома
днями раніше королева ще прийняла Тарас
у бал моралі
королева Єлизавета II була скелею на
якій була побудована сучасна Велика
Британія за її правління наша країна
зросла і розквітла завдяки їй Велика
Британія стала великою країною
у п'ятницю колишній принц а повертається
до столиці як король шукає близькості до
народу і його приймають і з великою
теплотою та прихильністю
[музика]
увечері у першій телевізійній промові
короля його мати знаходиться поряд
[музика]
Я знаю що і смерть є осередком Великого
смутку для багатьох із вас я понад усе
поділяю відчуття втрати
тепер у своїй 73 роки він повинен швидко
зорієнтуватися у новій ролі однозначно
рахуючись із зустрічним вітром а в
королівській родині яка останнім часом
часто ворогує є ознаки того що гори
знову зближає молоде покоління принаймні
на цей момент
поки частина Європи перебуває у спокої в
Україні продовжується війна зараз
українським військам вдається витіснити
російські підрозділ із окремих районів
за які ведуться бої на північному сході
та півдні країни але поблизу фронту на
Донбасі лікарями санітарам важко
Лікувати всіх поранених бійців саме там
працює медсестра ромашка яка стала
знаменитістю
наприкінці вересня Італія обирає новий
парламент передчасно після несподіваного
падіння у липні уряду Маріо драггі
Джорджа меллоні може сподіватися на те
що очолить новий уряд
останнє опитування показують що вона
лідирує її партія брати Італії ніколи
чітко не дистанціювалась від фашизму
Брюссель давно стурбовано дивиться на
Італію та успішно передвиборчу кампанію
джорджій Мелані адже які в місті Перуджа
і часто вдається набирати голоси своїми
сумнівними посланнями
останні приготування на 5 це Кватро
новимбре у перуджі
колись цей регіон був оплотом комуністів
цього вечора тут виступить Джорджія
меллоні головний кандидат відправив
націоналістичної партії брати Італії її
прихильники із нетерпінням чекають на
виступ
ми схвильовані і радіємо її приїзду сюди
наша Джорджія Для нас вона радше подруга
ніж лідерка
виступи джорджі і Мелоді
45-річна жінка вважається харизматичною
розумною і небезпечною
здається вона точно знає що хочуть
почути її прихильники
із самого початку вона переходить в
атаку вона звинувачує лівих в
агресивності критикує ЄС за нездатність
впоратися з енергетичною кризою та
стверджує що останній уряд Італії підвів
людей вона ж каже мелоні Навпаки буде
завжди ставити італійців на перше місце
Дозвольте мені пояснити нашу позицію
щодо міграцій вони наговорили вам про це
багато дурниць чекаю на вас із рушницею
Ні а Зачекайте я з цим не згодна
справа націоналістка намагається
здаватися поміркованою але вона швидко
дає зрозуміти чого хоче більш жорсткого
підходу до іммігрантів із глобального
півдня
[оплески]
це призводить до проблем безпеки так
проблем безпеки але це не вдається
пояснити лівим вони солідарні жінками
які зазнали нападу якщо на них не напав
нелегальний мігрант тоді нелегальний
мігранти здається їм важливішим
зазгвалтовану жінку ці висловлювання
подобаються багатьом і тут як здається
нікому не заважає те що у партію мелодію
проникли прихильники колишнього
диктатора Муссоліні І що вогонь на його
могилі є символом партії
в Італії ми повинні приймати нужденних
іноземців але перш за все ми повинні
думати про себе
вона така пристрасна така чітка і
зрозуміла навіть коли говорять про
складні речі
Утім критики малоні попереджають що
правопопулістка змінить Італію та її
цінності
Антоніо пічіні працює у давній
антифашистській організації
ampi
і він не вірить у новий поміркований
образ мелоні
фашизм ніколи не залишав Італію він
існує серед нас тепер він лише змінив
своє обличчя свій вигляд але він все ще
тут
наступний день кальярі на сардинії права
кандидатка заявила про себе таку ще тут
кузіму ладу не буде дивитися виступ але
каже що ознайомиться із ним
серединець має на острові кав'ярню та
чотири маленькі готелі але його дуже
хвилює майбутнє спочатку коронавірус
тепер різке зростання цін на енергоносії
він розчарований політичними партіями
ми підприємці не отримали жодної Вигоди
від жодного уряду Нам потрібен
довгостроковий план а не просто якісь
дії які тривають якраз 365 днів
програма мелоні загалом розплив часта а
її партія до цього часу відмовлялася
брати будь-яку участь в уряді але Саме
через це вона і може виграти
багато італійців явно хочуть бачити в
уряді нові обличчя зокрема Mercedes усай
у нас скаржиться на те що в Італії стає
все важче заробляти на життя чесною
працею
Я працюю у приватній клінінговій
компанії водночас Я працюю позаштатною
вчителькою у початковій школі тобто щоб
жити вам потрібно дві роботи
щоб виживати щоб виживати
точні наміри джорджії мелоні залишаються
насправді невідомими чи дійсно вона хоче
зректися по сташиською спадщини своєї
партії Ми вирішили Запитати пані мелодії
чи вилучити ви зі своєї партії не у
фашистів
відповідати на запитання цього вечора
кандидатка не хоче однак коли вона
виходить на сцену то попри всі заходи
безпеки зіштовхуються і з одним
демонстрантом
Я хочу мати право на шлюб і усиновлення
дітей гаразд
кожен чомусь Хоче чи є цей інцидент
справжнім Чи це постановка сказати важко
але в будь-якому разі лгбтк активісти
побоюються правої націоналістки мелоні
ми боїмося що ми повертаємося назад у
часі
що замість покращення наших прав і
просування прогресивних ідей ми
повертаємося в епоху якої боїмося
поки мелоні завершує цього вечора свій
мітинг під охороною поліції постійно
відбуваються невеликі протести молодих
людей після виступу Мерседес усаї у
захваті чи не заважає їй те що
демонстранти називають мелодій фашисткою
коли вони називають нас фашистами то я
як і Джорджія Мелані Кажу Мені байдуже
Якщо так вважають багато італійців то
права популістка має хороші шанси стати
першою прем'єр-міністркою України
або не виглядає так ніби з іншого світу
здається що вони ніби линуть у воді і в
них вагітніють не самки а самці морські
коники безперечно належать до
найчарівніших морських істот особливо
добри вони почуваються на густих
галявинах морської трави але саме це
середовище існування знаходиться зараз
під серйозною загрозою зокрема
Середземному морі найбільшу небезпеку
становлять рибалки та їхні Сіті на
півдні Португалії де кількість морських
коників значно скоротилась морські
біологи роблять усе можливе щоб краще
захистити цих маленьких чутливих тварин
[музика]
вони зачаровують людей упродовж
тисячоліть у багатьох культурах морських
коників вважають міфічними істотами
полонили вони також і його Жоржа палму
біолога із морською дослідницькою
станції фару що на півдні Португалії він
уже 15 років вивчає кісткових риб
[музика]
мене справді захоплюють ці тварини Вони
зовсім інші
такі цікаві ніжні і вони просто
відстоюють своє середовище проживання Я
люблю їх досліджувати
то що вона посередині Лагуни РІА хурмоза
і з виділеними охоронними зонами що є
справжнім раєм для морських коників
[музика]
більше ніде Вчені не виявилось тільки
екземплярів але тваринам загрожує велике
небезпека
перший дослідники оцінювали запас
населення Лагуни в один цілий два
десятих мільйона 3-4 роки тому він
становив лише приблизно 150 тисяч це
величезний спадок
однією проблемою є рибалки
навіть якщо франсіскому Ліна та його
колеги не посягають на морських коників
Вони завжди потрапляють у сіті
Вони живуть у морських водоростях якщо
сітка лежить майже на дні то вони
застрягають
цей чоловік також рибалка
руїни
перед лагуною руї любить морських
коників він виріс Разом із ними і знає
зони дерибальство заборонено
але він також знає що порушники спокою є
завжди
захищена територія починається приблизно
тут де ми зараз знаходимося і тягнеться
ось туди
проблема не в професійних рибалках
А в нелегалих які заходять сюди і
застосовують трави захоплюючи ними також
і морських коників
Жорж біолог її шукає крихітних креветок
їжу для свого розплідника морських
коників для нього проблема складніша
просто вилов рибалок що можна пережити
набагато більше вони загрожують
середовище існування чутливих тварин
своїми сітями
незаконний вилов риби призводить до
руйнування довкілля вони захоють у
лагуну на один раз а постійно багато
ночей підряд так руйнується їхнє
середовище існування
тому Жорж шукає альтернативи і
експериментує зі штучними водоростями
зі своїми колегами він заклав у лагуні
уже цілі поля і здається що морські
коники сприймають матеріал
морським коникам цей матеріал
подобається Хоча він і штучний але з
часом він стане схожим на природний бо
там оселяється інші тварини
тож штучне середовище існування стане
природним
рибалці руїць цього недостатньо Він каже
що необхідно сильніше запобігати причині
проблеми незаконному вилову риби у
заповіднику Він вважає що багато рибалок
проникають сюди не підозрюючи про це
оскільки вони цю територію навіть не
впізнають
[музика]
світ було позначити територію боями щоб
ніхто сюди не запливав
Я її знаю бо я тут живу
якщо наприклад хтось приїжджає з іншого
регіону Португалії то він тут губиться
[музика]
ідея з боями справді займає Жоржа та
інших вчених
зараз вони збирають кошти для
встановлення у лагуні системи
сигналізації принаймні Джордж вважає що
це Варто спробувати головне врятувати
морських коників
якщо тварини звідси повністю зникнуть що
я сподіваюсь ніколи не буде то це буде
величезна катастрофа для захисту цілого
виду проте Ми якраз зараз помічаємо що
запас дещо відновлюється і це дарує нам
надію
надію на вид які зачаровує людей вже
впродовж тисячоліть
і якому зараз загрожуються між люди
майже в усьому світі а не лише у їхньому
Раю у лагуні рія формоза
і якщо таких людей як Джордж палм буде
більше то цим маленьким істотам може
бути легше і в інших місцях
ви дивились програму У фокусі Європа
цього тижня це був наш погляд на Європу
над і під водою Наступного тижня ми
повернемось знову а до побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром
медіа-ініціатив переклад Володимира та
Олесі Швед режисер Павло Тимченко текст
читали Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та
Олесь гоян Київ 2022 рік
[музика]